To study what's going wrong when trying to solve stiff differential equations numerically,
we'll typically looks at this type problem of very simple differential equation
which by the way is not stiff but serves to help us understand what's happening here.
The derivative of x with respect to time should minus a constant times x itself.
This constant is supposed to be a positive number that's called Dahlquist' test equation
and it's easy to figure out what the solution should be.
The rate of change is proportional to the current value with the negative proportionality constant.
This means that per time step, we are losing a specific percentage of the current value.
If we start here, we lose that specific percentage and lose that
particular percentage and again and again and again.
This is exponential decay, so we know that as t goes to infinity, any solution will approach 0.
This decay to 0 takes place regardless of the value of k.
As long as k is positive and this proportionality constant,
any solution is going to decay to 0 regardless of the value of k.
If k is larger, this decay is faster. If k is smaller, this decay is slower.
And of course, we want that our numerical solution has the same behavior
when we simulate this equation in the computer, we want to see the decay to 0.
Technical term here is stability. How small does the step size have to be for the solver to stay stable?